[Musique]
aujourd'hui je suis à blois dans le loir
et cher c'est adele a vu naître l'un des
plus grand prestidigitateur de tous les
temps jean eugène robert houdin le plus
grand des magiciens à l'origine de tous
les grands trucs de la magie
d'aujourd'hui cette passion de la magie
il est transmise à arnaud d'haleine
maître de l'illusion qui m'attend à
l'intérieur de la maison de la magie
robert houdin à la vache et oui je suis
déjà là c'est le vrai ce n'est pas une
illusion je peux toucher je suis bien
réelle mais qui est trop fort le mec est
trop fort
[Musique]
tu revois la ba oui quelle quelle
vitesse de déplacement je connais tous
les secrets de la maison d'un magicien
le sens que ça sent le tour de magie
alors cette corde à les spéciales le
secret il est très facile salutaire est
là debout deux extrémités ok mais là où
ça devient intéressant c'est qu'on peut
les enlever
j'étais d'exécution 5 regardant la deux
bouts sans corde que je vais laisser
dans la poche juste la nage et une corse
en boucle c'est assez embêtant donc le
mieux pour moi est de remettre et vous
sur la corde le premier match c'est pas
compliqué on prend à bout on lance
l'autre et si on attend quelques
instants hors norme allemand les boues
reviennent ça raccrochait alors tu m'as
est-ce que je peux essayer moi j'ai drop
en as tu pris 6 1 les éparses mais au
petit prend un goût hop tu vois ici hop
tu tournes cut up mais qu'est ce qui se
passe absolument rien cummore espace
absolument rien ça ne me viendrait trop
fort pour aujourd'hui tu es directeur de
la maison de la magie qui est quand même
une entité quoi et oui c'est un lieu
unique en europe qui rend hommage à
l'art magique et notamment un personnage
principal qui est jean-eugène
robert-houdin il a réussi à
révolutionner l'art magique voilà c'est
grâce à lui que la magie est entrée dans
les théâtres c'est à lui que l'on doit
le costume dit du magicien c'est à dire
la veste queue de pie noeud papillon
chapeau haut-de-forme baguette magique
cette image traditionnelle on la doit à
ce célèbre magicien l'histoire
je tends peu des prestiges c'est un oui
nous sommes dans le temple des prestiges
qui retrace toute l'histoire de la magie
avant jean eugène robert houdin c'était
quoi la magie à l'époque il faisait quoi
si on remonte par exemple à l'époque de
l'antiquité on parle pas de magicien on
a des images ou des prêtres qui
présentait des non pas des tours de
magie il servait de trucages pour
impressionner le peuple il y avait des
systèmes qui permettait d'ouvrir les
portes du temple le peuple pensait que
c'étaient les dieux qui ouvrait les
portes alors encore en réalité il est un
subtil trucage caché sous le temps créé
mini on va retrouver soria au dernier
étage qui va te présenter quelques tours
de magie ok voisins venus en avance
jaret toute l'ue
c'est une oasis et pattes noires
[Musique]
dont le début par là
bonjour surya bonjour bonjour excusez
nous alors qu'est-ce que vous pouvez de
montrer les ravages vous on vient on va
faire un tour ensemble je vais te donner
un morceau de ce fils et tu vas faire
exactement comme moi tu va montrer ton
morceau tout le monde
les a vus et on va le cas c'est ensemble
joël on perd tout et petits morceaux je
suis d'accord que je vais faire une
petite boulette comme ça et là je vais
te demander qu'un mini est ce que tu as
une formule magique un geste magique
quelque chose
attention est-ce que ce geste a
fonctionné eh bien oui je crois qu'on
peut l'applaudir des forges
culture va compter jusqu'à trois est
ensemble on va claquer des doigts 1 2 3
vous avez vu camille est devenu
invisible
pour devenir visibles parce que j'ai
quand même une émission a présenté moi à
oui je crois c'est qu'à munich on entend
là mais non camille en fait ça fait
trois ans que je fais ce tour mais j'ai
jamais c est la fin